mom what are you up to oh just book
reading are you chewing the post mommy's
going a little crazy down here so I need
to get out and they know you're worried
I'm gonna go out there and kill somebody
but think about all the people I haven't
killed literally everyone in the world
except three people I just think you
should keep a low profile till we know
what's going on I'm just gonna act like
old she laughs system mirror and chipper
and never had an orgasm while eating a
man's liver hmm I think our killer looks
too much like a kill room you know feels
like we copied it from a kill room
catalog is this you guys human body
parts down there work
it could be spreading a lot of people
have gone missing from Santa Clarita
lately we get rid of one cop and now you
bring another cop into our lives Jack
any more aggressive Oh it'd probably get
a lot worse I love you and we have each
other everything else we can figure out
what the [ __ ] is this
I'm actually looking forward to a day
without any life-and-death issues
someday if you have kids and you get a
virus and start killing people you'll
appreciate how well your mother and I
are doing I'm gonna shake [ __ ] up dream
big I don't want to stop living just
because I'm undead
[Music]
[ __ ] we need to figure out what caused
this so it won't happen to anyone else
we could save the world Oh today's not
good look we have a lot of old mirror
this is the biggest project of our life
what good is a housing development when
armies of flesh-eating ghouls are
filling the streets we both have really
good arguments I don't think we both do
don't get me never
I'm so sorry no family is perfect
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up I'm Gary
not today
[Music]